Mike hyung Creed but maybe a little bit
brewing Mike's are always frat boys
they're the kind of guys were like their
sports teams lose and many days later
they're still crying I'm sure the guys
have spent about 10 minutes on your
bottom that he sounds so douchey but he
would rock you in bed every Connor I
know likes to drink a little bit too
much they're just puppy donors we're
always really really hot but stayed
immature there's a good chance Connors
gonna try to show you his balls at some
point during the party I feel like
Matthew someone who could become a
leader
I like Mick I always called my Matt
Mackey I like loved calling a man and
Matt is like someone who's more like a
jock I feel like Matt Szczur pigs them
usually Alex's are sweet the name itself
is a sweet name Alex's try really hard
they very hard kind
I feel like Patrick's are really hot and
really responsible Patrick's become more
good-looking because they're funny every
CPH should be named Patrick he might be
a good financial planner exactly Andrews
our genius yeah Andrews they know
everything smartest person in the world
yeah especially think obey drool
yeah I've been an Andrew and Andrew drew
is a about that life he has dropped the
end off he's like I don't want that
he's like I'm drew Oh one syllable he
just takes yes so chill there Joe yeah
chris is horndog dirty horndog
they usually kind of freaky behind the
door yeah
this is trickery the name of a player
daiquiris definitely a play especially
with the cak oh but that Z and their
name gives them an edge so there's yeah
I think Zacks full rock in bed even in
their news bags but when I found only
one time only the act Ryan's are
douchebags Ryan's are Joan it's true
Brian's other players Ryan's are the
golden boys 100% without they can
Anthony Anthony Anthony's you're not
Anthony's are hot Anthony's are college
guys that date high school students they
usually ride a motorcycle
at least yeah most likely that that is
the name of the guy that buys you a
drink at a bar babe a sneaky they'll
rise and bite you in the butt
go back Tony then you say
tony is holding down the fort ben is a
great name I love the name Ben oh my
gosh I think Ben's are so creepy he
never was there a more creepy man than
Ben liked the name Ben it's more like a
cute hot name like her good sweetheart
Ben is capable of such weird [ __ ] Tim
kind of creepy creepy yeah oh my gosh
wills are cute no matter what wills are
cute well in there we have great hair my
circle of girlfriends they've all dated
a will and they've been all like amazing
I don't know what that means I've never
dated one that marks everybody works
that money they make it rain classy dude
he's like dapper marks are good for sex
so I agree wands are always sexy bonds
like mysterious yeah gives good back rub
see oh yeah he can also dance yeah
Cameron's a sexy guy it's always like a
mistake that they made it they're like I
liked him I love Hunter I don't hunt I
love Hunter that's a sexy great name
like the epitome of the guy that you
dream about yeah he's like minimum 16
you might be a country boy yeah but hey
he has a southern hospitality
exactly hunters I think are such hot
sexy names except I don't think you
meant exists she fell when I wrote he
can benchpress yeah you need to fix
something on your car they can do that I
can make you feel tiny oh yes